women don't like nice guys say they do
dumb
you know as well it starts a childhood
start to child little girls like little
bad boys like little boy gives little
girl valentine's day cards she don't
want him she don't want nothing to do
with him she wants a little boy to just
punch her in the back and run down the
hall
oh i love him
he's so cute
then you grow up and you marry that same
little boy and next thing you know
you're an oprah going i don't know what
i did to deserve this
it just ain't right
but yo you picked that man you chose
that man you know you could have had
nice boy roy but you picked ass with
mcgee
oprah i love ass whoop he's a good man
in between after because he reads poetry
the violence of blue rose of the red
time to kick a [ __ ] in the head
you know what i found out growing up
totally shocked me white kids are just
as shocked to find out black kids don't
talk back to their parents because we
are we hear them talk back to theirs so
i used to have a little buddy would come
over my house on the weekends a little
nate we'd be in my room playing video
games my mother used to come in the room
on us cussed me out for no reason just
scare the [ __ ] out of both
we'd be in the room playing mario
brothers she'd come kick open the door
like swat
we'd be on level fours
harry's how many times and i told you to
clean this [ __ ] room cut that
goddamn game off to clean this room i
come back this [ __ ] roommate
clean i'ma take that nintendo chord wrap
it around your neck and stick it in your
ass [ __ ] i ain't playing with you this
ain't no threat this is a promise try me
[ __ ] try me
my white friend would turn to me
offended like dude what the [ __ ]
she can't do that man this is your space
it's your area
she's violating your right to privacy
you should say something you want me to
go say something
i'd be so scared i started talking to
him like a slave from roots like he was
going to get me's and troubles
i like you nate i really do
my parents is good black folk that gives
me food that gives me sleeps
you get away from round hill with that
foolishness
my mother smacked the [ __ ] out the white
boy he turned into me with
when i say the genders i am only
speaking of two of the several hundred
that now exist
i would like it to be clear where i
stand i have no problem calling anybody
anything they wish to be called it is no
burden on me you can identify as a
shoelace if you want to
and i will call you zippity zimzer if
you ask me to
do i think it's a little silly yeah but
so is badminton and that's an olympic
event you know so
let me tell you something explain to
your mom over the phone how to fix a
computer problem when you can't see her
screen
it's quite possibly the most
excruciating form of torture even
possible if i was an intelligence
officer and you captured me and you
wanted to extract information from me
you need to [ __ ] some [ __ ] up on my
mom's computer you guys could call me on
the phone ready are you freaked out
break like a twig i will tell you
everything you need to know for the love
of god fix a computer fix it right now
you have to explain every excruciating
step toward like you're defusing a bomb
just calm down just listen to what i'm
saying click the red x
next to your comment okay do you see a
comment yeah just click the red x no no
click it no click
no click it's left button click means
left button no the mouse will drink the
wire in front of you the mouse you see
your blank screen okay [ __ ] it i'm
flying over right now
no don't put my flight i'll book it
myself your message that [ __ ] is great
the only bad part is you cannot pass out
around white people every time white
dudes
pass out around each other they always
do some borderline gay [ __ ] when the
guys are sleeping
frank fell asleep so he like stuck a
carrot in his ass and
put shaving cream on his balls like why
[ __ ] why would you do that to a
friend of yours they trusted you enough
to sleep around you gonna put a carrot
in his ass is that is that nice
i'll tell you right now if i put a
carrot in a black dude that [ __ ] will
kill you when he wakes up for some [ __ ]
like that that is an automatic death
sentence on the street
it's a wrap for you i'm going to kill
that [ __ ]
[Applause]
i thought y'all was friends baby
what happened
i i fell asleep this house right we was
drinking and i fell asleep to this house
and and while i was sleeping right
i'm just going to kill that [ __ ]
all right that's all you need to know i
grew up very stereotypically in hong
kong like like my real name is not even
jimmy that's my english name my real
name is man xing in canada is monseng it
stands for ten thousand success
i had very ambitious parents
and now i'm telling dick jokes and doing
tai chi on stage so
jimmy was just kind of like an arbitrary
english name that just sounded easy and
my dad he named himself richard
i was like dad why'd you name yourself
richard he was like because i want to be
rich
it makes so much sense
and then they named my older brother
roger after the james bond actor roger
moore
yeah but my brother hated that name he
was like man it makes me sound like an
old white guy
so eventually he changed his own name to
roy
so now he sounds like an older white guy
and now his full name is roy roger which
is
the oldest white guy to ever white my
kids caught me and my wife [ __ ] let's
let's just start
let's just start here the worst thing
about my kids catching us having sex is
that we were having sex in positions
that you couldn't play off you know
there's some sexual positions that you
could play off there's a lot of couples
here tonight i see you with your ladies
sir if you and your lady having sex and
your lady laying on the side of your
kids come bust in the room you can play
that off all you got to do is sit up act
like you're watching tv hey hey hey
[ __ ] out of here don't come back in here
to be done watching tv
if you real good and you got your bottom
half covered up when you sit up you can
technically keep [ __ ] while you
talking hey hey hey get get your ass out
the goddamn room
don't come in the goddamn room
your lady be trying to talk don't come
in here
this is my favorite part of this show
i saw a guy get up a cat the day said to
a cab driver he said learn the [ __ ]
language
i'm like what a piece of [ __ ]
by the way it's kind of nice when they
don't know the language
they ever call an uber like 5am to the
airport you take a little korean guy and
you're like this might be a nice quiet
ride
[Music]
then you're on the highway and he's like
weather is weird you're like [ __ ] you
learn the language
why do you have to do that
women time to fight for equality
brilliantly
right i mean brilliant
5 000 years
man we were fighting lions and tigers
and hunting buffalo
and when we were like
we'll just pick the berries you guys got
that that's
you guys all right
you guys are brave look at
wow so courageous look at you hunting
that buffalo
second they put air conditioning in
office buildings women are like we want
equality
march for it girls
[Laughter]
you played the long game ladies welcome
welcome
play the long game they never let me use
a calculator until i turn 15. but when
you're a kid when your parents tell you
can't do something what do you do you
rebel right so when i was 14 years old i
stole my brother's calculator and i
locked myself in my room and i started
rebelling i started doing math homework
locked myself in a room i was just
punching in numbers i was like oh man
this feels great you know
it's so wrong it's awesome
my dad was pissed he was knocking the
other side of the door and he was
screaming he was like jimmy
jimmy
what are you doing inside come out right
now i know you're using a calculator
come on right now
he unlocked dorney came in i went into
full panic mode so i just threw away the
calculator and i pulled out my pants
i was like that i was just jerking off
he looked at me and they looked at math
homework
[Music]
and he was like good
good very good
very good very good no means no that's
another one no means no it's like no it
doesn't
all right
[Applause]
look look no means no no that means no
all right but no stop it what are you
doing
oh my god
you're being so bad stupid
no
that's not a [ __ ] no
that means i want to do it but i'm
afraid you're going to judge me so i'm
just going to make it look like it was
your idea so you don't figure out that
i've already performed this act with 40
other [ __ ] people right
but then
then you go to court and you get a bad
read there's some guy reading it your
honor she said no stop it what are you
doing you're being so bad
yeah and you just sent me like she
didn't [ __ ] say it like that she
didn't see it like that
[Music]
[Music]
get up tight whenever i talk about porn
i don't know why this is right there how
could you not watch
porno it's right there
it's like right on your computer
how could you not watch it
like if like if two people were having
sex
right here
and i was telling jokes right here
how many would be looking at me
nobody
that's right man
it's not a weird thing
i get why people watch love stories i
get why you watch like a romantic comedy
maybe that's your fantasy you're like
someday that's going to be me i'm going
to fall in love it's going to be
beautiful and you want to live through
the characters i get that
that's not my fantasy
you know it's my fantasy i'm delivering
pizza to a sorority
[Applause]
and they can't pay for it
i travel i do travel a lot if i fly uh
delta if i buy a ticket through uh
delta's system my name in their system
is nathan and on my license my name is
nathaniel i do not remember making this
decision
but it's a big deal you can't just
change it i've tried i've asked delta
and they're like we can't and you're
like all right they don't know where we
go from here
you know if you can't do it who can do
it
uh do you call a senator is that what
senators do i don't know
how high do i have to go
what do you have to do you have to mail
your birth certificate in some moms give
their kids their birth certificates i've
never seen mine
i thought i was the proof of my birth
[Laughter]
and
thanks
and you get you got to melt in i'm not
i'm not a big melanin guy uh i've mailed
maybe four letters my entire life stamps
make me nervous you know how many do you
put on there i don't know uh
and they change the price of stamps and
they don't that's not in the news you
don't find that out on twitter
you
you have to find out from old people
they're the only people that know
yeah they're telling you they're like
stamps and up you're like okay uh
and they're furious you're like is it a
hundred dollars a stamp i've never seen
you that mad it's uh
i will never go through this process to
get my name changed so i just deal with
it and it gets brought up i was checking
the bag once and the guy behind the
counter sees my ticket says nathan the
license says nathanael and he was like
this is not good
he's like these names don't match and i
was like but they match right i mean you
can see the leap that we took to get
from one to the other
and he was like but they're not the same
as they did the same and i mean at this
point i was like if this guy finds out
people call me nate he's gonna lose his
might like he's
he's gonna call the police to be like
there's a guy with three names trying to
fight like if you guys want to shoot him
or something so
i was like what do you want me to do and
he goes you should go home that was his
honest
i mean
i can't believe you made it this far
i said let me try it shouldn't i just
try it you know i was like look i'll
give you that those names don't match
what i think is going to help a ton is
the picture on the id
i mean i think with 100 percent face
70 of the name that's 170 percent
i think i'll get through
and he was like look man i get it all
right
he's trying to relate to me this is
honestly i this is honestly what he said
he was like my name's joseph that's
what's on my license but if i buy a
ticket under my nickname bart they're
not gonna let me through
[Applause]